[Music]
[Applause]
Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst former NFL
and USC quarterback back on the program
good to see you again Mark let me um ask
you a question that has been a topic
here with some analysts if I remove an
A-Plus receiver in Tyree kill and
replace him with a couple of b or B plus
let's say three B pluses and take out an
A plus does that make Kansas City
better
oh
better worse hard to say
um I think most importantly is the
scheme and the way
um you know Andy Reid's gonna dial him
up in that specific scenario
other places might not work uh but a
place like that they're gonna run what
they run I don't know how many times
last night they ran flanker drive just
the shallow cross with uh Kelsey the 12
yard basic right behind it
um the other two guys on the other side
are running a go route and you know a 10
to 12 yard corner or out route I mean
they run it all the time they just plug
in different players and it works
um so it's hard to say that
you know you lose one guy and then it
becomes receiver by committee uh to
replace that one stud
but I mean those guys are rolling other
all I can say is that pick the
overturned interception was rough yeah
um and then
watching that game last night
um uh average get out of the game yes
yeah he's trying to get out of the game
and then he can't expand that flat route
that flat route's supposed to be a foot
race to the front pylon
and then the other guy has a chance to
work on his quick out route or stick
route on the inside Defender
and So Justin's expecting him to break
out
and there's just too much traffic in the
area I mean but why don't they you know
the signal is you tap your helmet that
you want to come out he was obviously
gassed how did they miss that and then
they go to him on that play
well they weren't throwing to him I
think he was trying to throw the out
route and he was expecting the inside
receiver to break out
expecting to uh Everett to run to the
pylon so you create space on the out
route the Quick Flat and then the stick
route
and he's tapping his helmet to get out
of the game and they're trying to go you
know Tempo because they got down to the
goal line they're trying to punch it in
well
they just locked him in I I don't know
I'm I don't know if I've ever seen that
I felt so bad for Everett for the you
know for Lombardi the coke the
coordinator for Justin it's like you
know and there goes the DB like Johnny
on the spot like it's a gift we're
trying to come up with a category
receiver cause interception RCI because
that that was an RCI as a former
quarterback would you be in favor of an
RCI category oh you're gonna get me in
trouble with uh with some wide outs and
and tight ends and stuff but listen does
it happen yes but you also listen as a
quarterback you get you get credit for
um you know the negative one-yard pass
that goes 90 yards so
you know I I enjoyed those let me tell
you
when you when you looked at Herbert like
this year to last year
is there anything that stands out uh
with him
um
I I still think he's barely figuring out
how good he is
um and my favorite story from there was
watching practice uh two years ago they
did a joint practice with the 49ers and
Coach Lombardi
um their offense coordinator he pulled
me aside and I said what's up with your
what's up with your QV man he sure looks
good like that's the guy who needs to
get off the bus first
just because he's like this Adonis body
and you know you let him get off the bus
first and everybody's like damn like wow
and that's the quarterback yeah that's
just the QB you know like they used to
do that with Troy Aikman and then the
rest of the Cowboys would come out you
know because he had that kind of
presence Carson Palmer you know those
big players and um and I said what's
this deal you know how good is he to me
he he's like a puppy with these big paws
and he doesn't even realize like how
good he's gonna be and uh he goes you're
never gonna believe this but we had
these deep out routes like double bench
routes basically 18 to 22 yards
um outside the numbers the the
receiver's kind of catching the ball and
tapping his toes on the way out and it's
I mean it's a big boy throw now
especially if you throw it from the hash
to the field and you throw it to the
wide side well
Justin for whatever reason had been
taught like oh I'll just go to the
boundary if I can and and they're on the
left half so he's working the left side
of the field
and the defense is set up in a way where
you know it's quarters to the field he's
got this deep out route like no matter
what
and he throws it in the boundary and
Coach Lombardi's like what was that all
about and he goes oh I just thought we
should work the house and he goes why
well that's just kind of what I've been
taught like I just worked the boundary
side
and he goes dude you've got every Club
in the bag he goes rip that sucker out
to the field any time you want you don't
have to explain it to me like nothing
and so they script it you know literally
the next day and he just rips this ball
Frozen rope you know goes through a car
wash without getting wet kind of thing
and just on a on a tightrope bam and
hits Keenan Allen you know on the Deep
out and and then uh the other one was
he's um he gets the ball tipped against
um who'd they uh scrimmage this year uh
the Cowboys the Cowboys are at their
practice and he gets a ball tipped and
the ball's a little wobbly
he immediately runs over to Lombardi
goes hey I just want you to know that
ball got tipped and he goes oh yeah I
know and he goes well I didn't want you
to think I threw a ball that was like
that bad like not a spiral you know like
he's uh he's one of a kind man he's
special man he's special but it feels
like we've moved on or the media's moved
on from the homes
like we take it for granted now does
that happen with quarterbacks that they
graduate that they they just we don't we
don't look at them with the fascination
that we once did
I think it's like expected now you know
and that's that's crazy because he's
again another special player the arm
angles I mean I remember when Rich
Gannon would hit that like sidearm you
know
Nobody Does it Like Mahomes he's on one
foot kind of jumping out of the air and
hits these deep spear routes those deep
Crossing routes once again 18 to 22
yards in between the halfs and the
numbers opposite side of the field and
he does it like
almost
you know in his sleep and
I feel like people kind of moved on just
because like yeah that's what he does so
okay you know LeBron's on your team well
you're expected to win a championship
and if you don't then well that's you
know you're underachieve but we're still
fascinated with Josh Allen like he's
still in that bubble where there's a
Fascination level but but it might you
know we might move on from him soon
um if if you were advising and I know
you know Josh well if you advised him on
anything
what would you tell him
oh man the only thing I've ever told him
was get down get out of bounds don't get
hurt why won't he do it
oh he's one of those guys who needs to
you know not get his Bell rung you know
I'm not
he doesn't need to get hit hard
but he's not like in the flow of the
game until he gets hit and
um he's got to get his jersey dirty
you know they're designing quarterback
runs for him I mean look at the guy he's
massive you know he's put on this Earth
to play NFL quarterback he's a big guy
and so he can withstand some of those
hits but is he like Cam Newton just a
better passer
I think he's better from the pocket yeah
I mean he'll just beat you from the
bucket straight up you know even if he
doesn't rush at all in the entire game
and you say you know
um if he plays with a boot on you know
he's got like a broken foot or something
he'll still be from the pocket and that
is that's rare that's but if these were
stocks if these were stock we're talking
to Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst if
you're buying a stock
the quarterback stock that you would buy
into
because it would make sense you know
maybe Buy Low sell high are we in a
recession
what's going on here we we are we're not
in a quarterback recession
noted so are you would you buy a stock
like Trevor Lawrence would you buy a
stock like Joe burrow would you buy a
stock like
Justin Fields Aaron Rodgers
I mean I'm I'm uh
I'm hanging on to Herbert I'm hanging on
to Alan I know Allen's and you can only
buy one stock One stock just one yeah
one stock and at its current value what
did I do wrong why do I not have any
money to buy it
you cashed out you didn't play long
enough in the NFL and you USC didn't pay
you as much as you thought you were
going to get paid
what kind of car did you get at USC
oh dude I drove a two thousand
one or 99 Honda Accord stick shifts that
we got in an auction for like 3 500
bucks I like it don't did you ever hear
but I had a car did you be outside a car
and it was stick shift so nobody else
could drive it it was awesome did you
ever hear the Ed orange run story where
he was trying to recruit Adrian Peterson
what do you say Peterson's dad was in
prison in Oklahoma
Ed O was trying to get his dad
transferred to an LA County jail so
Adrian would play for USC yeah so
because whatever it takes because I'm
going to play in front of my dad
Trojan family man that's what we do you
know how do you feel about your Trojans
this year are they should they be
considering their own title National
Title contender
we're rolling now
um we can't slip up this week Fresno
State will jump up and bite you if
you're not careful so
um I love the way that offense is
playing I know everybody's you know down
arrow speaking of stocks everybody sell
sell on the defense like all right give
them some time give them a little time
and they're coming from the Big 12 you
know that's uh that's kind of the mo out
there
score 45 give up 38 still take the w
so
um I think I think it's just rejuvenated
the program and and that tailgate a
couple weeks ago was so fun
um just seeing people excited about it
again it means a lot you know and and
you don't realize that
when you're in college but finally
when everything's said and done and you
get to go back to your school and
everybody's excited about football again
and it's back that's I mean that
Coliseum was rocking man and that and
not to throw shade at Rice listen uh
coach bloomgren is their head coach he
was one of our coaches in uh
in New York but um
it was just nice to see it was really
cool but if you could pick you had to
pick one in your USC you could beat
Notre Dame or beat UCLA
yeah people ask that all the time I
think nationally yeah you want to beat
the brakes off of Notre Dame
um
but it was one of those things with
Coach Carroll he didn't really mention
Notre Dame as much
um and he always told us the story like
you know the first time we were doing
Notre Dame and I was here as the SC
coach I you know I was talking about old
school and the three Horsemen and this
that and you know and talking about Rudy
we're like watching the movie Mark
there's four horsemen
what whatever
um so
same difference so
what did I say three yeah all right yeah
and they had that movie about that guy
Tommy no it's Rudy it's it's Rudy too
and Thomas you know Jim Montana went
there no it's Joe Montana win one for
the slipper no it's Skipper all right
you get it we get it
good job Lee
um it's the it's the pewter Dome no it's
the golden dome
all right I'm done Touchdown Jesus
in your case in your case it is yeah
yeah in your case it is Touchdown Jesus
thanks a lot guys
um no so he goes into the whole you know
uh history and and all the stuff and
noted and they Notre Dame just beat the
brakes off of Pete the first time they
did it he goes screw that man we're not
even talking about them we're going to
show up the day before go kick their ass
and get out of town you know like we're
not doing that anymore did you have a
hard time understanding Pete Carroll
because he talks as fast as anybody he
has no punctuation in his sentences Mark
it's like when my mom first started
texting you know it's just all one long
word one long paragraph Just I love you
mijo hope you're doing well you know
um no I I uh I really enjoyed them and
that was his thing just own L.A and and
that was their that was um uh Ed ogeron
sarc Kiff all those guys
you're competing for everything
in L.A we own la uh the same you know
they would say the same girls you're
chasing in L.A hey we gotta win
you go out to a club we get the best
table we get a better table than that
you want to go you know get some gas you
get in line before them we own la you
know it was just like no macro that's
awesome I used to love it the way they
talked about it so we gotta get back
there always good to catch up with you
thank you Mark appreciate you guys thank
you that's Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst
former NFL USC quarterback obviously a
great historian of Notre Dame football